we watch and work for vaccines to be
available to all
remembering the millions who've died
from covert on the outskirts of the g7
summit
while among world leaders gathered here
a debate is emerging
on the best way to save more lives
inside the summits politicians have been
talking about sharing
hundreds of millions of vaccine doses
but to prevent more deaths
billions will be required is it time now
for the west to
share the knowledge of how to make
vaccines it's an idea that's dividing
the g7 but gathering support
even at the top of the u.n
sky news has highlighted the massive
task that lies ahead
in total we will need uh let me estimate
uh
two million doses two million dollars to
be at the secure site
our reporting in lesotho shows that just
a fraction of what's required
is reaching the people who need
vaccinating
more vaccines are on their way but not
enough
should vaccine patents now be lifted
do you think that the situation with
covid is so grave that the patents on
vaccines should be lifted
but it's not just a question of sharing
vaccine shots but sharing the knowledge
to make them that's important yes i mean
it's obvious that we need to share the
knowledge
not only share the knowledge share the
knowledge and share the the
the all the aspects necessaries to allow
for
doubling the production of vaccines and
for that
we need to be able to mobilize all the
capacities that exist
already aid agencies and charities say
lifting patents on vaccines
would massively increase production we
need an agreement by all g7
leaders and at the world trade
organisation to share the vaccine
science and know-how free of
intellectual property barriers
so that more qualified manufacturers
around the world can make them
developing countries are not asking for
charity here they're asking for the
rights and the recipes to make these
vaccines themselves
on a cornish beach campaigners highlight
the split between britain and america
opposing lifting patents with other
countries in favor
dividing the g7
at current rates it'll take an estimated
57 years for the vaccines to reach
everyone
in the developing world and all the time
there's the risk of a new
vaccine-busting variant
emerging if we're not careful by
vaccinating the rest of the world
i'm calling it a covenanting guacamole
we are going to be perennially fighting
a variant after variant
we need to vaccinate everybody
everywhere now
in order to stop this ongoing crisis
with cover 19 we won't win
unless and until everybody's vaccinated
everywhere
one way or another vaccine production
needs to ramp up
before the virus outwits us again
dominic waghorn sky news falmouth